welcome back to CBS mornings and we have
an update to a story we told you about
in January on how a medical coding
change could limit reconstruction
options for women who have lost a breast
to cancer and want to avoid implants we
partnered with kff health news to learn
more and met a young mother from Central
Illinois to see how some patients are
fighting back we should point out
following our earlier report the
government agency that oversees coding
set a hearing to review the change
that's tomorrow consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Werner has more
and we got some squish Kate Getz never
thought she'd become an advocate for
breast cancer survivors she's an
accountant and single mom to daughter
Nora and then go wash your hands she's
eight she's in second grade but this
past January doctors diagnosed her with
breast cancer and told her she needed a
mastectomy it's not news that you expect
to hear at 30. it's a scary moment then
she had to figure out what kind of
breast reconstruction she wanted she
knew she didn't want implants because
the FDA says they should be replaced
every 10 years instead she wanted a
natural reconstruction using what's
called a deep flap procedure in which a
surgeon removes skin fat and blood
vessels from a woman's abdomen
essentially doing a tummy tuck then uses
them to create a new breast with her own
tissue the problem she couldn't find a
surgeon in her area to do it then she
saw our CBS news story from January
explaining that a change in the way the
government codes the procedure is about
to make that deep flap surgery even
harder to get some insurance companies
had already started sending out letters
like these saying their reimbursements
to doctors would drop drastically as
Texas breast surgeon Dr Elizabeth Potter
told us then make no mistake women who
want this surgery and have money will
always have access to it the only people
that this coding change affects and
hurts are women who need access through
insurance I felt like I was on just a
ticking Time Bomb there's only so much
time for me to get this procedure before
my insurance company won't pay for it
anymore sure enough when she reached out
to her insurer Cigna it was already
lowering its reimbursement the company
told her in this March 29 email that it
would only pay for the Deep flap under
the new lower paying code gets faced the
task of finding the rare surgeon who
would accept that lower insurance
payment her only other option pay tens
of thousands of dollars in in cash it's
not even an option I'm a single mom we
get by right but I'm not Wealthy by any
means now she's become one of many
voices pushing for the code change to be
reversed on social media she called out
Cigna posting this picture of her
mastectomy scar why did you do that I
felt highly motivated that women needed
to start sharing their stories
I felt like the only way we were going
to get insurance companies to change and
to roll back what they were doing was
they needed to hear us I think they need
to see us and I think they need to hear
us but how did that code change occur
the centers for Medicare and Medicaid
services or CMS the government agency
that oversees coding pointed to the
American Medical Association but when we
asked the AMA they told us they never
asked CMS to get rid of that higher
paying code so who did we found this
document from 2021 showing that the
lobbying Association that represents 34
Blue Cross Blue Shield insurance
companies Nationwide submitted a request
to discontinue the higher paying code
for deep flap saying it was no longer
needed medical coding researcher Dr
Karen joint Maddox says the
association's move the insurers
presumably decided that they wanted to
pay less
and took the Tactical approach of trying
to get that procedure rolled back under
a code that was a less expensive less
resource intensive lower paying code the
upshot of that is that women who need
this procedure are left to put the bill
it sounds like you're saying that maybe
patients were left out of the equation
here
I think patients are generally left out
of the equation unfortunately as to the
coding change the BCBS Association now
tells us we are examining our position
and are currently in discussion with our
member plans in April Cigna agreed to
pay the higher reimbursement under the
old code forgets to have a deep flap
reconstruction and told us in a
statement they have paused using the
lower paying code and are reprocessing
deep flap claims it is surgery time on
May 15th Getz had her surgery but she
says she's not done advocating for other
survivors I'm fighting for women around
the country to have access to the
surgery sounds like you're going to keep
fighting yeah
I'm here for the Long Haul
both Cigna and Blue Cross Blue Shield
told us and kff health news they're
committed to preserving affordable
coverage and access to care including
cygnaced surgery for breast cancer
patients and by the way Dr Potter did
Kate getz's surgery she had to travel to
Texas mind you to get it done but Dr
Potter helped her out yeah I mean
insurance companies are for-profit
organizations so they're also committed
in addition to their customers to their
shareholders and they want to make a
profit so there's that accusation that
they shifted this code in order to make
a little bit more money they say no but
we'll see that's a great point though
you're not making an excuse but people
have to realize it is for profit yeah
it's a business well the question in
this case really is
is there a middle between this higher
paying code that micro surgeons say they
need payment for a more complicated
surgery and it really they're saying you
really just can't jam it under a lower
paying code and say that's enough
because you're limiting the availability
only to women who have the money to pay
cash tens of thousands and should that
be the case I think most people would
say no yeah agree yeah all right cool
thank you very much appreciate